INTERVIEWER: In a
lot of ways, this
just looks like graffiti on
a wall, the type of thing
you'd see anywhere.
But with that
ghostly white writing
and the floating,
faceless hoods,
there is also something
haunting about it.
The picture was
taken by this woman.
CECILIA BRODER: Hi, my
name is Cecilia Broder,
and I'm from
Littleton, Colorado.
INTERVIEWER: Cecilia took this
photo in Bariloche, Argentina,
while traveling
around the country.
CECILIA BRODER: I was
wandering around Bariloche,
and came to the central square,
and noticed these painted
throughout.
I took a few pictures, and
then asked what they were for.
I then began my learnings
about the Mothers of May,
and what these paintings
and names represented.
INTERVIEWER: The
Mothers of May are
a group of Argentinian women
who came together in the 1970s
to raise awareness of
their missing children,
a group known as The
Disappeared," who
went missing during
the Dirty War,
a time in Argentina's history
when a military dictatorship
ruled the country, terrorizing
anyone who spoke against them.
CECILIA BRODER:
Many of the mothers
came together in their grief.
They began to
demand to be heard,
wanting to know where
their children were.
When they were not
given any information,
14 mothers began, on April
30, 1977, a silent vigil
in the Plaza de Mayo
in Buenos Aires,
the site known for protests.
More joined them, and it became
a weekly event on Thursdays.
Standing there silently,
they were identified only
by their white
kerchiefs, and some
with pictures of their
missing children.
INTERVIEWER: It was a horrific
time in Argentina's history.
The government would
silence its protestors
with extreme violence,
kidnapping, torturing,
and killing up to
30,000 citizens.
CECILIA BRODER:
Azucena Villaflor,
one of the founding
mothers, whose name
is written in the central
square in Bariloche,
was kidnapped outside her home.
It was reported that she was
taken to a torture center,
and was on one of
the death flights
to the middle of
the ocean, where
victims were drugged, stripped,
and flung into the sea.
Her body washed up on a beach.
Families today still
wait for answers.
The mothers, now grandmothers,
continue their march
every Thursday at
3:30, making sure
that Argentina doesn't
forget this brutal part
of its history.
INTERVIEWER: And as Celia
walked around the plaza,
seeing the names of the missing
scrawled across the stone,
she felt for all the victims--
those who disappeared,
and those who are still
waiting for answers.
It saddened her, but she also
took away something else.
CECILIA BRODER: From looking
at simple paintings and names
on a plaza, to understanding
the history of a nation,
I came away with a deeper
understanding of the word
"courage."
The courage of these
women, then and now,
exemplifies the love
and bond of a mother
with her son or daughter
that can never be broken,
no matter what.
INTERVIEWER: "This
Happened Here"
is a photography series that
showcases fascinating images
and the stories behind them.
If you like this video,
be sure to check out
this one on the daily
life of Cuba's youth.
Cuba continues to
face restrictions
under their government,
from their press
to their internet access.
The cost of Wi-Fi
alone makes using
the internet impossible
for the average Cuban.
Thanks for watching.